joining me now with reaction congressman
James comer and dr. Deena Grayson who
ran for Congress as a Democrat in 2016
all right Dana now explain to me how
Democrats with this legislation that has
no chance in hell of passing they aren't
trying to completely alter the American
electorate with this bill no what
they're trying to do is the most
American thing possible which is empower
people to vote I mean in order to have a
functioning democracy we need people to
go to the ballot box and vote and so
what this is doing is allowing people to
register to vote more easily declaring
Election Day a federal holiday which by
the way we're one of the only few one of
the only democracies in the entire world
that that does not have either election
day on a weekend or have election day
being a national well we have election
day Dana we have election day that
stretches for weeks and sometimes months
how did we possibly survive congressman
comer as a constitutional republic well
my mother was a waitress my dad worked
at Pratt winning aircraft they somehow
managed to get to the post it was only
one day right now we need to have at
home registration use your ears your
computer same-day registration now why
is that happening it sounds like oh it's
so easy how did we ever function before
no thing's legitimate until we have
instant voter registration absolutely
this is the just what McConnell said the
Democrat political protection act
they're trying to build upon what they
did in California all the shenanigans
they pulled in California with the
ballot harvesting they're trying to be
creative this is not the answer people
are empowered to vote it's easy to vote
same-day voter registration that's a
backdoor attempt by the Democrats to get
more people to vote that are not legal
citizens and that's their game plan to
try to beat Donald Trump in 2020 and
we're not gonna let it stand in the
house Deana here's another thing that
I'm disturbed by as someone is more of a
federalist on these issues is what's
happening with states rights and all of
this this bill would usurp state
authority to set voter ID also I believe
on felons whether whether felons could
vote or not and that's traditionally
been a state prerogative this
a sweeping usurpation of states rights
in my view how do you react to that
again I can't think of anything more
American than empowering our citizens to
vote what if they don't want about Dana
what if I have no desire to vote and
they don't hire no no they require you
to be registered its your right as
American citizen to be left alone if you
don't want to be registered to vote why
the heck does the government have any
right to tell you you have to register
to vote what's the constitutional
provision you're relying on they're not
forcing you to go to the ballot box
Laura I mean they're forcing you to
register what if you don't want to
register
well we from choice what about the
Selective Service we force everyone to
register for the direct cause of wartime
provision that's because of an emergency
wartime provision no that's not
everybody right now
every man that has to register 18 acts
because that's because it's a national
emergency we have to be able to mobilize
people quickly this is not mandating
that someone as an individual who does
not want to vote has no desire to vote
should not be a not have to vote or not
have to be registered to vote it's it's
the same stuff they want to do on doing
registration national Democrats think
more government's answer to everything
and this is another example of more
government let's talk about what the
Democrats think about sixteen-year-olds
voting I love this okay people think
this is like a internet like like total
hoax that this isn't true
but that's right because Democrats today
voted to support the states that want to
lower the voting age to 16 Dana
well my understanding is that provision
actually did not make it in the final
bill there was an amendment that was
proposed to allow 16 majority of
Democrats voted for it but it didn't
pass but what it is allowing is for 16
year-olds to basically kind of pre
register to vote and again don't we want
our youth to get involved and be ready
to vote and get excited to vote once
they turn 18 and that is part of the
bill and I think that's a great thing
for America congressmen are you against
the youth voting are you you and the
Republicans must just hate the youth and
you don't want them to we want everyone
to vote but I'm astonished that the
Democrats want to raise the age
Americans to be able to own a gun or to
be able to purchase tobacco or alcohol
but they want to lower the age for
voting
we have no nothing that stands in the
way of young people voting today I'm all
about more people voting and I think
that we have a great democracy and the
Democrats are continually trying to
change that to benefit themselves Gina
do you think illegal immigrants should
be able to vote in the United States
well they're not allowed to vote I mean
I think my question is if you people
with someone's been here ten years they
maybe have fraudulent identification but
they are paying taxes out of their
salary shouldn't they have I'm talking
as a as if I were playing a Democrat
today shouldn't they have a right to
vote I believe in a path to citizenship
and once you have citizenship I think
that all citizens of our country should
be able to vote you're a raging
conservative in the Democrat Party Dena
that's why we love having you